Hello everybody. My name is Markiplier
And I'm here to ask you
How well do you know Markiplier?
So we gotta quizzzz here
that says "How Well do You Know Markiplier"
HARD VERSION  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
So let's put it to the test.
I've got a bunch more quizzes so I can
figure out who the fuck I am
Anyway, SO answer the question buddy
What is Mark's full name.
Mark Plier
Mark Edward Fischbach or
Mark Edwards Finchbach
Which is an amazing name and I would love to be called that.
But frankly, I have to answer honestly.
To my own ideals...
which is this one.
Which university did he go to?
University of Cincinnati.
Who is Mark's sibling?
Thomas Jason Fishbach.
Well, that's not correct.
None of these are correct!
It's not Michael Jason Fischbach.
It's not Thomas Jason Fischbach.
It's not Sabrina Edward Fischbach.
It's never Lily Edward Fischbach!
Because my brother's name isn't Thomas Jason Fischbach
It's Jason Thomas Fischbach
Yes! You heard it here first.
I have revealed to the world
That my brother's REAL FIRST NAME
is not Thomas as
he would have you believe. NO. NEIGH.
He goes BY his middle name.
So I guess is... None of these are correct! hehehenghere
How old is he? Well, pretty damn old..
But not THAT old..
and not THAT young.
And definitely not that young.
What was I doing when I was 20
I have no goddamn idea!
I was still in college...
I still had hopes to be an engineer *laughs*
and not a- not a dumb Youtuber on Youtube!
But I'm 27 and proouud of it
Do nit wirry, Izzze iz a professonel.
I've never said those words in my life.
When was he born?
Well, judging by the previous question *raising his pitch*
You'd be able to extrapolate an answer of maybe
MAYBE just maybe I was born in 89.
Where is he living right now?
How the heck am I suppose to know I'm not a stalker.
I'm gonna answer that one.
That's all folks! *mumbling*
What is this?...
I answered 6 of 8?!
WAIT 6 of 8?!
Wait a m-Woah hang on a second
WOAAAH hey, wai-Hang on
What did I answer wrong?
'Cause I know I answered one of them wrong
*Mark is still in shock*
*Mark stuttering*
*mooing*
Let's try this again on a different quiz
and hopefully, there is gonna be some correct answers here
and not some bullshittery in the background.
Mah name is THAT.
I was born on this date!
I was born *giggle*
on a O'ahu Hawaii. GOD
Why does everyone say O'ahu Hawaii
say, Honolulu 'cause that's where I fucking was
Not on an air force base!
It was an army b-Its a mili
Whatever it was
fUcKiNg dOeSn'T mAkE aNy sEnSe!!
Why is everyone saying O'hau Hawaii.
It's fucking Honolulu.
I was born in Honolulu.
There where I wa- Honolulu is on O'hau
but you know what they don't say?
that you're fucking in on O'hau.
O'hau Hawaii doesn't make any fucking sense!
It's Honolulu.
Oh! OH Whats that! OH
FUCKING UH
O'hau... FUCKING Honolulu!
Here, let's zoom in on this.
Military...hossspital
Tripler YEAH. There we go
Tripler Army. Here!
I was born here! It's fucking pink.
*music stops*
That's- It's fucking pink.
That's where I was born!
Pink mustache and all, right out of my momma!
Just, pft. "Hello everybody!"
I just, thats *laughs* how I was born
I just burst out and everybody in the room, fully clothed and muscular
"Hello everybodyyy, My name is Markiplier.
and I'm going to be a Youtuber when I'm 27.
But before that I'm going to fail a whole lot of everything."
*weird chuckling* *disappears*
Alright, anyway continuing this bullshit quiz.
In-In
Honolulu
In a hospital. I wasn't born...
Like when people say that I'm born on O'hau
on an air force base.
Which I don't think there is an air force base
On O'hau but I'm not sure about that.
That makes it sounds like I was born...
in the middle of the runway.
My mom, sprinted out into the field
*Momiplier voice* "OH I'M HAVIN A BABY"
That's not how my mom sounds like
I'm sorry mom
My mom is probably watching this
I'm sorry that's not how you sound I know that.
She sprinted out onto the tarmac
dropped trout, then had a baby on the runway *laughs*
I'm sorry mom, I'm already commited
I've already apologised so I gotta keep going with the joke
So that's what that that's what that sounds like
Anyway, so...not to get sidetracked
Let's see. Which movie had Mark starred in?
Starred in, Starrred in
YOU KNOW, The Rock's one movie?
That one movie that the Rock did?
The-The Rock movie?
You know, the Rock movie?
The Rock? with George Harrison
Wilson- Wilfred Brimley and uhh
The guy for the SAW movies?
Yeah, you know I was in the Rock movie
*mumble* yeah that was me. I was that guy.
I didn't star
I haven't been in any Youtube Red Movies
I was- I- I had a little *stutters*
little thing in the Smosh movies
What was Mark's first video?
No! That's a lie! its- This is a lie!
It's a damn dirty. I know if you go to my chan-
I-I'm fully aware of the fact that if you GO
to my channel. And you sort by oldest.
You get a very diff-Ohhh fuck
We're not gonna watch my-Let's do a video
where I watch my videos.
I know- I know if you do
oldest, it will be like, Oh! It's the amn- It's this video.
Uhh this one uhh this one.
NOOOO!!
That-that's not the first one.
This is the first one.
This is the first Let's Play
I've ever done
Old mark:  Hello everybody, this is Markiplier here
with my brand new
let's play of Amnesia The Dark Decent.
Notice all the spit that's in my mouth
It's because I didn't know how to talk properly
and I didn't know how to enunciate and I never talked before.
We're gonna do a side by side comparison to see how 4.5 years of time that's passed by to evolve the voice that is me.
Alright,
Hello everybody, Markiplier here with my
brand new let's play of Amnesia: The Dark Descent.
Just gonna create a profile here
I heard this game is quite scary
Old Mark: Alright everybody, this is markiplier here
with my brand new let's play of Amnesia: the Dark Descent.
Just gonna make a profile here, I've heard this game is quite scary
Current Mark: BOOM! Got it! Nailed it!
Do it side by side, fly by, do lots of passes on this one
See, it's me! It's ju- it's fucking me!
I dunno what - I dunno what point I'm trying to prove here
LOOK! IT SOUNDS LIKE ME!
but from five years ago!
It's fucking me still, it still, it
listen to that! huh?! it's weird right!
The voices! Ah, whatever, fuck it
I don't know
My point is - again, I get sidetracked in these quizzes-
My point is, it- it-it's not- Amnesia, my first one
was the first part of Amnesia: The Dark Descent
Because I had to play the game before I could do the compili-
Get it? It's on my old channel, I can show you it
You go to youtube.com/user/markiplier
Oh! It's me! It's old me!
Even older than old me. It's original old me.
It's like ancient old me. And look!
It's the compilation! And then
This one, this sad video here
Old Mark: Hello everybody! Markiplier here, and I have a very very important announcement to tell y-
Current Mark: It's me!
Old Mark: It's the most important message that I'll probably ever get to you guys.
for...
Current Mark: Absolutely the most important message huh?
You didn't think you had a more important message than to tell you
guys that my channel died? See you
ever wonder why my youtube channel is markipliergame and not markiplier?
Because *incomprehensible* youtube fucking deleted my adsense on this one!
Fuck you youtube!
Coulda had mark -- look it's my old icon!
The old, original icon I used to have!
FUCK
Again, I got side tracked.
Apologize, not the point of this.
What is Mark's most popular video?
Good question, I have no idea.
Probably Five Nights at Freddy's.
YEAHHHHH! It is.
Next one is Five Nights at Freddy's and Yandere
Ok. Lot's of fnaf.
Meow?
Ohhhh Meow is still pulling through!
Ohhh Meow is close to my heart..
Eventually I'll make another video like Meow.
I do plan on that very soon.
Its gonna be-uh-it's gonna be special.
I already have the idea for it.
So
I'll do tha- I'll do that soon. I'll do that soon actually.
This is about dedicating like.. so many hours of just cutting out my mouth
and it's very boring
Awwwe Babyplier
Tiny Box Tim
aghhh that's so cool!
Man, what was with these games and getting a bajillion views? That's so weird.
Man ok.. but why..  WHY does that have 8 million views??
Holy shit.
Man, this is like flipping through memory lane..
Like my god..
OHHH
Popcorn's up there?! I love popcorn!
That's both a statement and a happy about that thing!
Oh that's cool.
I really haven't looked at this..
Oh man I haven't looked at this is a long time..
OHHHH MARKIPLIER WALKS DOWN THE STREET!!
YeeeEESSS!
Oh let's watch it again!
I don't care.. fuck you!
Yeah I happened to make a video where I watch my own video
CAUSE I CAN! CAUSE THAT'S ME!
How well do you know Markiplier?
*weird noises* If you're *weird noises* not suprised I'm doing this bullshit.  *10 seconds of dancing Mark*
God.. How long ago was that?
Oh god it was last year.
Agh fuck
It wasn't that *giggles* long ago *giggle*
Oh man
Oh jeez.. ahh it's memories..
What was the point of this??
Wha-What am I doing here?
I-It's funny because people go to these videos over time and like
people find them over time and like it's such a mix of very old videos that are popular
and then very new videos that are popular
I always like looking back at what I've done but usually I only look back at the old videos and then more recent videos
It's just kind of like..
I dunno it's kinda jarring to be looking at this stuff and remember each one individually.
like.. god this is like the MOST click baited thing I've ever done.
Markiplier get's banned from Youtube.
and it's just like i was-we were just talking about the story about allegiant park.
good god.
and we did a video at Allegiant park.. it's a very lovely place.
Ahhh the first video I did with Jack..
Awwwww Drunk Prophunt.. the only thing we ever did of that
Ah man.. god that was such good times
it's weird because going through this and jumping through all of time
It's really like
it's heartwarming for me
because it's like seeing all that I've accomplished
and that's what I like about the videos that I've been doing recently
especially going out with fans and what not
because I can look back and they're memorable
it's not just a... throw away video that
I put up because I needed to put up a video
it's videos that I can remember and look back and I know
exactly what was happening there
and I know why it was happening
and I know what was going on in my life
I'm getting lost in nostalgia now
this is not the point of this
it's just cool to see. Anyway
I'm done being nostalgic and being bullshit
let's face this quiz out
it's FNAF part 1, is the answer to that
What year did Mark start making videos?
we just went over this! it's 2012
What YouTube group is Mark apart of?
Revelmode
There's an easy one.
What color did Mark first dye his hair?
And it was pink.
Last question, but it's easy! How tall is Mark claim... why!
I claim, I claim I'm a great many different heights
I think 4'2 is the most common one though
BAM!
I'ma genius! I know me!
Do you know me? 'Cause I know me!
And that was a fun, fun adventure
I like taking these quizzes, it seems weird on the surface
to take these quizzes and look at them and be like
"Oh man what is this silly crap"
but the reason I do it is because it makes me remember.
Like it makes me remember not only what I've done in the past
but what I do
is like ingrained in you guys' minds
so that's important for me to put out good things
so that you remember good things about me.
I mean I guess you can still remember bad things about me it's totally fine, too
but my history is all laid out in these quizzes
and it brings up memories, and it brings back good times
and bad times
it can bring up sad times too
but that's important because it's part of your past
and it's a part of my past in this scenario, so.
I hope you enjoyed this one, this one was a fun adventure
I really didn't know where this one was gonna go
and it went to some pretty surprising places, so.
Thank you everybody so much for watching,
and as always, I will see...
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to this video where I ask
you guys, in real life
how much you know about me.
Because... Apparently, it's not a lot.
Mark: How old am I?
Woman: 26
Mark: Wrong.
Woman: Damn it! (laughing)
Mark: Well that's a lash, Alright
*grunting*
Mark: Where was I born?
Woman: California
Mark: Wrong *giggles*, no. pshh
Mark: Would you believe me if I told you this mic doesn't work?
Man: Yes
Mark: and I've been wasting everybody's time.
Man: No.
Mark: Where was I born?
Man: O'ahu? Hawaii?
Mark: Did you say O'ahu?
Man: Yes
Mark: You get the whipping prize, you said O'ahu
Mark: I've been looking for someone to say that forever.
Mark: Not really something I should take a hard stance on.
Mark: Anyway, you fail.
Man: Okay.
Mark: Alright, bend over.
Tyler: Ohh that was really good.
Mark: Sorry
Do you want to give me? In return?
Tyler: You don't want me to do it.
Mark: Do it as hard as I did it to you.
*Mark winces in pain*
Mark: Who's your favorite YouTuber?
Woman: You, that's all I watch.
Mark: You know who my favorite YouTuber is?
Woman: you
Mark: MEEE
Mark: It's true. *Woman giggles*
Mark: name?
Mike: Mike
???: Oh, Always taller.
Mark: Place of origin?
Mike: California
Mark: Ethnicity?
Mike: White hispanic.
Mark: Favorite color?
Mike: Red
Mark: Where did you go to school?
Mike: High school or college?
Mark: Pick your favorite.
Mike: Uhh Warren High school.
Mark: Alright, so you didn't like college?
Mike: No, I dropped out
Mark: Me too!
Mike: Yay!
Mark: Anyway.
Mark: Yeah what's my favorite color?
Woman: Green
Mark: Yaaay! *Cheers*
Mark: One, you get a reward lash.
Woman: Oh goddammit.
Mark: Alright, what's your name?
Alex: I'm Alex
Mark: Okay, what's my name?
Alex:Mark
Mark: fuuuull name!
Alex: Mark..iplier
Alex: Is it your full name? *breaks out into a giggle*
Mark: We got a jokester here.
Mark: We got ourselves a jokester.
Tyler: Who's his favorite YouTuber?
Mark: Yeah who's my favorite YouTuber
Woman: That guy right there *Tylers breaks into laughter*
*demon laughing*
Mark: So congratulations, any closing thoughts?
Woman: um... My brother and I love you?
Mark: Aww, thank you very much
Mark: What is the first video I ever uploaded?
Alex: Um, it was a Minecraft video?
Mark: No!
Mark: How much do you know about me?
Woman: Not very much unfortunately.
Mark: This quiz is gonna be fun then.
Woman: yeees
Mark: I'm from... I was born in Hawaii
Woman: Oh really?
Mark: Yes
Woman: Oh well that's nice
Mark: I'm not Hawaiian.
Woman: Oh, cool. alright.
Mark: Okay.
Woman: That's great.
Mark: Good.
Mark: You failed the quiz.
Woman: I'm sorry
Mark: You have one redeeming question.
Woman: I know
Woman: Okay, it has to be easy
Mark: What was your name again?
Victoria: Victoria
Mark: Okay bye
Victoria: Bye
Mark: Congratulations
Victoria: Thank you
Mark: You were wonderful.
Victoria: What did I win?
Mark: Nothing. 'Cause remember?...
Mark: you lost.
okay goodbye!
*Victoria breaks out into laughter*
Mark: She's tryna dodge
Tyler: She's dodging!
Mark: What's your name?
Jasmine: Jasmine
Mark: Okay, what are you doing here?
Jasmine: jussst...
Mark: When was I born?
Jasmine: A month and a day and a year?
Mark: That is correct! Technically speaking.
Tyler: How many youtube channels has he had?
Jasmine: Don't you have like two?
Mark: The answer is actually four.
Jasmine: oh
Mark: Markiplier, Markiplier2, Markiplierlivestreams, and then Markiplier games.
Jasmine: Ah. see, now I know.
Mark: Now you know. The more you know
Mark: Alright you failed the quiz alright goodbye.
Mark: What's going on? Tyler: You okay?
*Crying* Woman: I'm just so happy because I was able to meet you and my brother always wanted to meet you but my
Woman: mom and brother and my family-friend passed away this year *hugs*
I'm so sorry
Woman: I'm so sorry..  Mark: Aw It's okay. *woman crying*
Mark: It's okay.
Woman *crying*